you ever feel frustrated when a show
wraps up before the long summer hiatus
and leaves things unresolved hey it's
just a season finale you'll get closure
when that show returns in the fall but
then there are some long-running TV
shows that ended a season on their
cliffhanger and then got cancelled here
are some shows where audiences never got
to find out what happened Mork & Mindy
elevated by the staggering comic gifts
of Robin Williams this show's fourth
season run came to an end in a truly
weird fashion an evil alien named Kel
Nick tries to kill Mork and Mindy but
they escape using a pair of magical
time-traveling shoes but oops they're
damaged and the pair go too far back in
time the last image a cave painting of
Mork and Mindy did they ever get back to
the future we'll never know because this
show got canceled sliders on the final
installment of sliders a show featuring
a cast of dimension-hopping characters a
psychic tells the crew that if they
slide through space and time just once
more they'll die however they find a
loophole if one of them slides but also
injects themselves with a special tonic
they'll be okay the character Rembrandt
does it and slides on through does he
live does he die the psychic could tell
the others but while fighting off the
team's enemies she dies freaks and geeks
freaks and geeks made stars out of the
cast members like James Franco and Seth
Rogen but when this show aired in 1999
it finished near the bottom of the
ratings NBC canceled it before all 18
episodes were broadcast one of the
seasons story arcs followed Lindsay Weir
and her struggles with whether or not to
remain a hard-working school first good
girl she ultimately ditches an academic
summit to go to a Grateful Dead concert
at the end
Lindsay hops in a van and it drives away
and we never know if Lindsay made it
there or back my name is Elle this had
come followed around an amiable dirtbag
named Earl played by Jason Lee who wins
the lottery and spends his life making
amends for all the bad things he's done
despite being a big hit for em
see it was abruptly canceled at the end
of season 4
in 2009 the last scene drops a bombshell
Belle's actually the father of his
ex-wife's baby and she's about to
explain that the episode and series ends
with a to be continued graphic NBC Lois
& Clark the New Adventures of Superman
each decade gets the Superman it
deserves sad post-watergate seventies
america got happy positive Christopher
Reeve and superficial Melrose Place
loving 90s America got this soapy Super
Show starring Dean Cain and teri hatcher
season 4 ended with a super seeming baby
left on Lois and Clark's doorstep was it
from Krypton like Superman who knows ABC
decided a fifth season wasn't such a
super idea
angel toward the end of its run angel
and his gang take on an evil law firm of
Wolfram & Hart the final scene of season
5 shows the protagonists preparing to
storm their enemies the show's creative
team didn't intend for this to be the
ending but they learned too late that
they weren't getting renewed so they
ended the show on a cliffhanger but
created Joss Whedon is okay with that
satisfied it suggests the fight against
evil never truly ends thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which cliffhanger
frustrated you most